and it's great to see you here at London
Film on comic-con today I know it's your
first one of these events it's and how
you enjoying it so far I'm having an
absolute ball that is wonderful actually
got off the bus and I ran up to the
queue because there were two people
dressed as Daenerys and Jon Snow and I
went up and I said excuse me
can I take my photograph with you and
they're like who's that weirdo I haven't
seen them yet so I'm hoping they kind of
see me later on brilliant really
enjoying it's fantastic what are you
looking most forward to about today I
think just did actually speak to the
fans of the show it is just amazing I'm
a fan of the show myself I love the show
I love being a part of it it's a real
privilege to be part of it but to see
the enthusiasm and the affection that
the fans have for you know all the
characters and all the different
storylines it really makes you feel
special and really really makes you feel
great I think they showed isn't it you
know real love I think it does and the
fans are so incredibly loyal I mean
they're just wonderful and I don't think
I've ever had a job where people have
stopped in the street and just you know
talked about the story and it's just
wonderful and because I mean I we my
wife and I are huge fans of the show and
we can't wait till next week so we
recorded them all and then we watch them
over 10 nights so I'm only on Episode
five season four and I actually have to
tell people don't tell me I want to add
everything five don't no spoilers no
spoilers but it's great now and that's
really what's very special about a day
like today really enjoying it we can
talk about some of the scenes that
happen before then and also some your
own scenes because everything you know
what happened in though the purple
wedding you involved in that way and you
tell me what it was like you know
filming Joffrey's death scene and what
was it like watching it back and see on
screen well one of the questions I get
asked a lot is what is Joffrey really
like and Jack is one of the nicest kids
you're ever going to meet so for me I
found it very very difficult to film
that scene because I wasn't going to be
working with him again so in that sense
I actually found out seemed very
difficult as a scene I thought it was
spectacular the director
grace was just incredible and he had the
whole scene from start to finish in his
head at any given second he knew where
the camera had to be he knew what the
actor had to do it was just a real buzz
to be on the set for that week and then
whenever I saw that saw played back I
thought my god
that's pretty of that scene may just go
down in history
but Santi because I wasn't going to be
working with Jack again and that was sad
about that even though we love to hate
and I mean and either pirelli an actor
in the part Jack
he really is wonderful because people
genuinely hates Joffrey and they expect
you have to be the same and Chuck is
without a shadow of the nicest kid I've
ever met
he's just gorgeous lovely wonderful
generous lovely lovely boy so I'll be
very very sorry to see him go but yes a
brilliant doctor
a brilliant doctor he died I do think
his character will probably go down in
history as one of the best bad guys ever
and that's a lot of credit to him and
one of the other thing too involved in
the season which I know you have seen
yet but you will fill this Tyrians trial
wasn't it yes that was fun what was
actually my the most embarrassing day
I've ever had on set because I had a
speech to do in it and I couldn't get it
right I just I kept fluffing it and this
was the first day and it kept fluffing
him and there are five hundred extras
behind me and 250 crew and I'm getting
more and more uptight and Alec Sakharov
wonderful director and a really lovely
lovely man kept on calling said it's
okay it's okay no no it's not okay this
is all but I actually said him by Friday
I will have this speech I will know this
speech and when I'm 90 I will know that
speech okay and wasn't their first time
they have threatened Joffrey right here
in this throne room he marched up those
steps
slapped our King on the place comparing
our grace to the Mad King and suggested
he made the same fate and when I spoke
in the Kings defense he threatened to
have me killed
told you
it's shown your heart for life now
that's it that'll be on my gravestone
well not bloody speech but it was a
great scene to shoot and again a real
buzz whenever you're shooting the scene
that is so big and the scale of this
show would take your breath away bring
it now and I think it's something you'd
have seen already but it won't spoil it
for you if you have a the hounds at one
point refers to Meryn trant's characters
yeah you see that so he tells them that
he's not very impressed with your skills
and he says that you know any boy [ __ ]
could defeat three Meryn trant's they
what have you got to say about that yeah
well Rory McCann I work we're not Rory
McCann many years ago on Alexander and a
lot of you viewers don't know that he's
a wuss okay
he might be six foot five and he might
be really tough but I'd like to see him
take on ser Meryn Trant I say anymore
with any luck now of course it was
referring to there was because I made
the Williams character thought that
Syria who has been killed by Meryn Trant
didn't see it on the screen did we know
what's your story for that could span
some fans are saying no was he killed
maybe he got away will we see him again
I have not spoken to mr. Martin about
this yet but I would find it very
difficult to believe that Marin hadn't
killed him
I don't think Maron would let him get
away especially this little half wooden
sword no he's dead that's what I think
some fans may disagree I don't know I'll
have to wait and see I think if we lose
so many great characters on the show
we're kind of reluctant to see them go
aren't we I think you get so emotionally
attached to characters and then whenever
you see them leave the show it's
horrible
I mean I speak as a fan the times that
I've been sitting in front of the screen
going oh my god they didn't just do that
did they and honestly and you do you
invest so much emotional time and effort
into these wonderful characters but I
think that's what's magical about the
show I think it's what's absolutely
fantastic feeling literally don't know
what's gonna happen next
I'm not as the most exciting television
I've ever seen I've honestly loved every
single minute I have been on the show it
has just been a pleasure to be a part of
a privilege they're part of it I have
been working with some of the best
actors in the world the best crew it's
just wonderful
I just love every minute of it and I
don't want to die I don't wanna die
season five well I don't know I'm there
I'm there so we'll have to wait and see
I don't know yes it'll be a surprise for
me to do anything in game it's right so
what would you like more insurance to
get see you next week kill Ron just kill
Ron I like to kill people by killing
people
I'm good at killing people yeah I like
to kill people if you give fans a
message out there what would you like to
say something um thank you thank you you
are the most wonderful fans in the world
and you're so passionate about the show
and I'm a fan of the show too and just
thank you if your passion for your long
I'll be there wonderful very welcome
thank you
you